[Musique]
le bus arrive dans six minutes on est
parfaitement dans les temps
je suis ta cours de maths ce matin ouais
vous faites contre montréal j'ai pour
vous de la géométrie chevaux
moi j'ai été nul en maths
ok
plus que cinq minutes
pourquoi tu me parles pas d'opa non tu
me parles part si je te parle au nom se
plaisent à c'est relou ça reprenons t'as
quoi comme cours ce matin je sais pas tu
ça peut te [ __ ] hockey et tu as prévu
de manger à la cantine à midi
ouais sûrement comme question c'est
possible
qu'est ce tu fais sur ton portable je
passe d'un tweet rtc ta mère te casses
les couilles en attendant le bus hashtag
mère hashtag relou hashtag couilles a
donc je te casse les couilles mais non
c'est pas ça assez complètement hashtags
et ben je sais pas parler d'un truc
c'est intéresse pas n'importe quoi
qu'est ce qui t'intéresse
je sais pas je vais des joints jouer
avec nomination aux prix des snapshots
de matavai des meufs me branler sur du
porno allemand sur l'excellent non stop
bon tu peux et un ton truc non mais
n'interrompt pas c'est très instructif
amis déjà tu arrêtes de m'appeler rémy
saha prénom de molosses tout le monde
m'appelle cadavres je savais pourquoi tu
as pris cette appli là parce que tu ne
parles pas tu voulez que je fasse quoi
je sais pas je pourrais me laisser
tranquille
à thé de péter les coups il a été
question à la con si je parle pas c'est
une raison de tête tu saoules à la fin
pareil tu fais pitié avec ton appli moi
si je peux a lancé un quoi tu veux tout
savoir tout le temps quand tu veux
absolument me parler je sais pas parce
que je suis ta mère je t'aime
[Musique]
hashtag malaise